[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى وجهنا لوجه سعاده
فقط تفصل التونسيين عن انطلاق حمله اول
انتخابات تشريعيه في عهد ما بعد الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو وجمله الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس سعيد
وسط تجاربات المستمره بين المعارضه
من الاحزاب التي كانت ممثله في البرلمان
السابق انتخابات انتقادات عديده بدايه من
القانون الانتخابي مرورا بالتزكيات
والتمويل وعدد المرشحين الذي لم يتعدى
عتبه الالف سوا بقليل اقل من خمسه من
النساء على خلفيه كل هذه العوامل اي صدى
للحمله لانتخابك التي تاتي وسط مخاوف من
عزوف في الناخبين وقلق حول شفافتها هيئه
الانتخابات التي عاجنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
ومن المتوقع بالنسبه لاقتراع يطعن البعض
في شرعيه قبل ان ينظم اساسا اسئله وغيرها
اطرحها على ضيفك من لسه العاصمه بدايه
السيد رضا بالحاجب القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه وعلى الجانب الاخر يرحم ايضا
بالسيد محمد علي البغدير يعود مبادره
لينتصر الشعب سيده اهلا بكما معنا على
قناه فرانس 24
هذا البرنامج وهذا النقاش اسالك هناك
مخاوف كثيره تسبق ليس فقط هذه الانتخابات
انما ايضا الحمله الانتخابيه قد ذكرت
بعضها في المقدمه المخاوف من العزوف انت
باعتبارك عضو في مبادره لينتصر الشعب التي
تدعم قيس سعيد واجراءات الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو هل تتفهم هذه المخاوف
اييي شكرا اولا على الاستضافه بالعكس
تماما هناك انخراط واسع لعموم التونسيين
في مسار هذا التوجه وهذا المسار الجديد
لتونس
والدليل على ذلك هو
مئات الالاف من المزكين المترشحين وتعرفين
جيدا انه ما تقدم الى هيئه الانتخابات
اكثر من 700,000 تزكيه ولكن اؤكد لك بان
المئات الالاف الاخرى مالت موجوده ولكن
اصحابها لم يتوصلوا الى تحقيق الرقم
المطلوب 400 هناك حركيه كبيره في الشارع
التونسي
للمترشحين الذين همم جابوا المنطقه التي
يسكنون بها وهناك مشاركه للرجال وللنساء
وللشباب ايضا مما يباشر بان هذه
الانتخابات سوف تكون ناجحه وسوف همم
ادعاءات التي تريد ده الحمى الانتخابيه
التي تسبق اقتراع يعني من المفترض ان يكون
مهما غائبه عن الشوارع التونسيه
همم بالفعل هو هناك الطريقه القديمه التي
كانت تجرى طبعا بين اطراف سياسيه بين
احزاب همم اغلبيتها والهام منها تمتلك
المال وتمتلك يعني القدرات الهائله هذه
المره ليست ترشحات لقائمات تمثل احزاب
السياسيه بل هي ترشيحات الفرديه همم يعني
تعكس ومدى اشعاع المترشحين في المناطق
التي يسكنون بها وهي طريقه جديده فيها همم
صحيح بعض الوضوء ولكنه مختلفه لانها يعني
هناك غياب للتشاذب
الحزبيط الذي رافق كل الانتخابات الفرده
كما اعتدناها على الاقل اذهب الى السيد
رضا بالحاج في همم الجانب الاخر القياده
الخلاصه الوطنيه همم سيد علي البغديري
يقول لك بان الحركيه موجوده لا مخاوف همم
في الناخبين وان ربما المشهد اختلف هذا ما
هذا ما تغير مع هذه الانتخابات او مع هذه
الحمله لذلك ربما اا لا نرى ما اعتدنا
رؤيته في السابق
سيدري طب الحاج هل تسمعني
يد يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال لا ادري ان
كان السيد رضا الحاج يسمعني
صدر باب الحاج ولا يسمعني احاول ربط
الاتصال مشددا بالسيد محمد علي البغديري
مجددا محاوله مواصلات هذا النقاش معهما
حول تونس وطبعا هذه المخاوف التي يتحدث
عنها البعض بالنسبه لهذه الحمله
الانتخابيه التي تنطلق بعد ساعات تنطلق
السبت بالواقع الانتخابات السابع عشر من
ديسمبر مع الاسف يقال لي ان الاتصال
بالضيفين قطع الصوره موجوده لكن الصوت غير
موجود بانتظار ان يحاول اصلاح هذا المشكله
هل سياخذ بعض من الوقت امننا
طيب سياخذ بعضا من الوقت على ما يبدو
ننتقل الى ااا تقرير
رسما نحاول اصلاح هذا المشكل التقني ننتقل
الى فقره في عمق الحدث المغربي الان ثم
اعود
كره قدم
21 عاما يلعب لفريق اولمبيك لمديه وهو من
الدرجه الثانيه في الدوري الجزائري يلعب
عبد المجيد في موقع المهاجم ضمن فريقه
ولكن طموحه ليس له حدود هو يامل ان يحترف
هذه اللعبه وينضم الى احد الفرق في اوروبا
اوروبا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
يبدا نهاره في صاله الرياضيه حيث يقوم
بتقويه عضلات جسمه يذهب بعد ذلك الى
الشاطئ ويقوم بتمرينات بدنيه يذهب لاعب
كره القدم المحترفون عاده على القيام بها
تحت اشراف مدرب متخصص
يخشى هذا اللاعب على نفسه من الاصابه
كاغلب لاعبي كره القدم في بلاده حسب قوله
هناك
[موسيقى]
اديني نعود الى ساعه المغربيه ونعود الى
النقاش او الى وجها لوجه بعض ان اصلحنا
المشكل التقني الذي حصل قبل قليل سنعود
الى ضيفين في تونس العاصمه السيد محمد علي
البغديري العضو في مبادره ينتصر الشعب
وايضا سيد رضا بالحاج العضو في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني المعارضه وجهنا لوجه مخصصه
لبعض قبل انطلاقها الحمله الانتخابيه
لتشريعيات التي السبت قبل طبعا الاقتراع
المقرر في السابع عشر من ديسمبر نتحدث عن
هذه المخاوف وعن من يطعن شرعيات هذا
الاقتراع قبل ان يبدا كنت قبل قليل همم
اذا همم سالت السيد محمد عليه البغديري
حول المخاوف من عثوفي الناخبين اعجبني بان
ذلك همم ليس صحيح وبان الحمله الانتخابيه
قد تتخذ شكلا غير هذه المره اذهب الى
السيد رضا بلحاج حول هذا الموضوع همم سيد
رضا بالحاج ماذا عن اولئك الذين يتخوفون
من عزوف المواطنين وهل انت منهم
شكرا طبعا همم هذه الانتخابات تجرى في اا
اطار انقلابه منذ 25 جويليه 2000 21
استولى اا الرئيس قيس سعيد على جميع
السولات همم وجمعها بين يديه حل البرلمان
بواسطه دبابه حل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء وكل
المؤسسات الدستوريه والهيئات القائمه
اليوم المسار الديمقرا المسار الانتخابي
ياتي في هذا الاطار الانقلابي وفي جو همم
يجمع فيه قيس سعيد جميع السوره القضائيه
التنفيذيه وصلنا قانون انتخابي على المقاس
اختار طريقه اقتراع على مقاسه بدون
استشاره احد قام باصدار مرسوم حديث الجانب
اختار الدوائر كما ي- كما يشاء همم اصدر
مرسوم
غير فيه تركيبه الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات بحيث اصبحت غير مستقله هو الذي
يسمي هو الذي يعفي
ومكانهم من حسانه تمنع مقاذاتهم كذلك
الاجواء العامه في البلاد اجواء خروقات
واعتداءات على حقوق الانسان على الحريه
الفرديه والعامه هنالك نواف همم
تحدثت عن همم مسار الاجراءات التي اتخذها
قيس سعيد الذي سيفضي الى هذه الانتخابات
تقول بان الرئيس همم يتحكم في همم السلطه
بمفرده لكن هناك من يقول ان هذه همم ان
هذا الخطاب يتغاضى عن ان هناك همم اطراف
داعما لقيس سعيد هناك مشاركين في هذه
الانتخابات هناك 1055 تقريبا همم مترشح
لهذه الانتخابات هناك حركه هناك اا حركات
سياسيه تشارك في هذه الانتخابات يعني وكان
هناك نوع من الاقصاء في كلامك السيد رضا
الحاج لهؤلاء
هذا المحكمه الافريقيه لحقوق الانسان
والشعوب اصدرت حكما اعتبرت فيه كل
الاجراءات اللاحقه ل 25 جويريه هي باتيلا
لجنه البندقيه كذلك التابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي اعتبرت همم الاجراءات التي قام
بها والتي تتعلق بالهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات هي منافيه للمقاييس الدوليه
للانتخابات النزيهه كذلك الاجواء اليوم
هنالك 10 دوائر ليس فيها اي مترشح هنالك
اكثر من 25 دائره فيها مترشح واحد هنالك
عزوف تام على المشاركه في الانتخابات
والناس تعلم ان اغلبيه الاحزاب 90% لن
ليست الدليل على ذلك 10 دوائر دون مرشح
لاول مره في تاريخ الانتخابات منذ 2011
ومنذر انتقال الديمقراطي هنالك 10 دوائر
ليس فيها اي مرشح وبالتالي ستكون فارغه
كذلك هنالك اكثر من 15 دائره فيها مرشح
وحيد الاحزاب الكبيره سواء من خلال نتائج
الانتخابات الاخيره او من خلال صبر الاراء
هي مقاطعه للانتخابات قيس سعيد يريد ان
يسوقه هذه الانتخابات للخارج بانها
انتخابات الجامعه الا انها وهنا اريد ان
الاحظ عن
شكرا انقل كلمه للسيد محمد علي البغديري
حتى يكون بينكما تفاعل في هذا النقاش
استمعت الى ما عبر عنه السيد رضا بالحاج
بالنسبه لهذه الانتخابات يقول بان هناك
كانت خروقات بدايه
صياغه القانون الانتخابي ااه مساله
التمويل ايضا ايضا قله المرشحين في هذه
الانتخابات تطرح عند تساؤلات تمثيل النساء
هناك تساؤلات عده تطرح بالواقع
كيف تجيب عنها
مازلنا لحد هذا اليوم يعني بعد اكثر من
سنه نعود الى ايام همم
ذلك اليوم التاريخ في حياته التونسيين
عندما همم فعلا استجاب رئيس جمهوريه لضغط
الشارع لضغط الجماهير التونسيه التي نزلت
بمئات الالاف في ذلك اليوم ونادت بحل ذلك
البرلمان ما زال الذي اساء الى سوره تونس
ويقع فيها الاعتداء على المراه داخل
البرلمان نفسه والذي همم سخن كل وقته
للسجلات الفارغه عبر الاهتمام بمشاكل
الرئيسي لذلك اليوم يعني يعني
وهذه وهذا التاريخ المفصلي يعني هناك من
اقالي انه رئيس سعيد
كانت لها انتقادات مثلا حركه 25 من جوليه
ابدا بعض الانتقادات بالنسبه لطريقه اداره
الامور
في معناه العديد من الايجابيات ولكن طبيعي
ان يكون فيها انه يقصد امر طبيعي همم
التونسيين كانوا يعني همم
متحمسين لما اقدم عليه الرئيس في اتجاه
تلك التدبير الاستثنائيه بالفعل التي جنبت
البلد الدخول في نوع من السيارات الداخلي
الذي كان يمكن ان يعصب الوحده الوطنيه في
تونس وهناك العديد من الخطوات التي تم
انتخاباتها تشكيل حكومه في تونس تتراسها
لاول مره لاول مره في الوطن العربي وفي
افريقيا امراه تقود في فتره الصحابه الى
امل الحدود في ظل الازمه عالميه كبيره
وارتفاع تضخم في كل بلدان العالم اثر على
الوضع الداخلي
ولكن هذا همم
لا محل لها من الاعراب رئيسه الوزراء
رئيسه الحكم
هذه المراه تشتغل في مجموعه
وتقدم مجهود كبير اكيد فيه
السيد رضا الحاج مساله الخروقات مساله
التزكيات مس
اله انتخابيه التي تمت صياغته من قبل
الرئيس كما تقول المعارضه مساله عدد
مرشحين القليل نسبه النساء كل هذه
الانتقادات
النساء اكثر من 140 امراه ونحن لن نتراجع
عن همم
النظام من اجل تحقيق المساواه الكامله بين
المراه
من اجل ذلك ونبدا بالمناسبه الا التونسيين
حتى يصوتوا والى المراه الكفئه الى هناك
العديد من النساء في وطني في هذا البلد
اللي هم من الكفاء العاليه ومن القدرات
وقدرات على تمثيل هذا الشعب همم
البرلمان المقبل لن تكون في مساواه بين
الرجل والمراه
همم للمساواه الحقيقيه هي على الميدان
هناك العديد من
الرؤى حول كيفيه تمثيل المراه نحن مع
تمثيل المراه تمثيل حقيقي نحن ندعم المراه
التي تتوفر لها كفاءات حتى تتواصل ولا
يمكن ان نستعمل المراه يعني ااا شماع نعلق
عليها ربما بعد الافكار التي همم اصحابها
هم في حد ذاتهم غير مقتنعين بالمساواه بين
المراه والرجل المساواه بل المراه ورجل
على ارض الواقع يجب ان همم تطبق والمراه
راينا تطبيقها بالفعل من خلال حتى الحكومه
الحكومه الدوله التونسيه التي تقوده امراه
وهي بالفعل معنا همم بالفعل قبل مجهود
كبير وادارت هذه المرحله الصعبه جدا في
تاريخ تونس هذه الانتخابات هناك اقبال
عليها هناك تنافس غير صحيح في همم بعد
الدوائر الذي هي مرشح واحد همم ليس لان
همم لا وجود مرشحين اخرين هناك العديد من
المرشحين الاخرين ولكن همم التزكيات هي
اللي كانت ربما احسنت بعض الصعوبات
الالاف من التزكيات الاخرى موجوده في تونس
استمعت الى همم حجج السيد محمد علي
بوغديري هل يمكن ان تقتنع
لا يمكن الاقتناع كل المسار انتخابي كما
قلت هو مبني اولا على اجراءات جاءت بعد
انقلاب وجمع للسلطات الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات اليوم هي تحت امره
رئيس الجمهوريه يستقبل رئيس الجمهوريه كل
اسبوع رئيس الهيئه ليعطيه التعليمات اليوم
الاخيره
همم تعاطي الهيئه مع هذه الانتخابات طبعا
طبعا
اليوم الهيئه العليا للانتخابات همم
تستولي على صلاحيات الهيئه العليا
للاتصال السمعي والبصري وتريد مراقبه همم
وسائل الاعلام في الحمله الانتخابيه راينا
كيف ان همم سعيد هو الذي يسمى هو الذي
يعفي الاجواء اليوم هنالك نواب في السجن
هنالك المحكمه العسكريه تلاحق العديد من
النواب والصحافيين هنالك رؤساء حساب محل
تتبع السيد فاضل عبد الكافي ممنوع من
السفر اليوم تونس في حصار والممارسات
الاستبداديه عادت اخطر من قبل الثوره انا
اتعجب اليوم كيف يقال من بعض رؤساء الدول
ان المسار همم الانتخابي يمكن ان يكون
جامعا المسار اقصائي همم قيس سعيد يشارك
طبعا اتحدث عن مكراه ومع الاسف في فرنسا
في ولاده الديمقراطيه بلاد عصر الانوار
بلاد
المفكرين الديمقراطيين اليوم تدعم
ديكتاتوريه محتملا بعد ان عاشت تونس فتره
من الديمقراطيه بعد اين موقف الفرنسي قبل
الثوره وكيف انها اخطات التقييم قبل
الثوره لا نريد ان تعيدك الكره وتخطئ قيس
سعيد ونظامه سوف لن يبقى
ونخاف ان فرنسا تكون اتخذت الموقف الخاطر
في هذه المرحله الدقيقه التي تعيشها تونس
ربما سنخصص نقاشا اخر همم تصريحات مقهوه
واقعها على المشهد السياسي التونسي اعود
اليك سيد محمد علي البغديري بدايه ما قاله
السيد رضا الحاج حول
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات مع هذا الاقتراع
وايضا ما قاله بشكل عام حول شرعيه هذا
المسار وبالتالي هذه الانتخابات في ظل
تراجع الحريات كما وصفه التي تعيشه تونس
اولا ااا
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات تجتهد
اكيد قد يكونوا كذلك كل عمل الانساني ربما
في بعض النواق ثمرات اخرى اعيد ولكن انا
اؤكد بانها معناه لها قدر من الاستقلاليه
وكل شيء نسبي طبعا في هذا العالم
اتها مباشره
تونس هو سينجح بالضروره لان هناك التفاف
شعبي حول مسار 25 جبيليا رغم الظروف
الصعبه ورغم يعني
المصاعب التي يخوضها الشعبنا ولكنه متمسك
بهذا المسار مدرك بان الخروج
فقدنا الصوت مع السيد محمد همم
كان يسمعني
مع الاسف هناك مشاكل في الصوت مع السيد
محمد علي البغديري
لايقاف البرنامج عند هذا الحد اشكر سيد
محمد علي البغديري عضو مبادره لينتصر
الشعب كان معنا من تونس العاصمه واشكر
ايضا من تونس العاصمه السيد رضا بالحاجه
القيادي في جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه
اليوم شكرا